we have a voicemail number and that
number is 219
to david p here's a question that
i can't tell if it's good faith or not
but there's a lot of meaty policy
discussion
that we can have as a result take a look
at this question
hey david it's troll man the
anti-intellectual i have a question for
you
right why do democrats insist on having
medicare for all when the medical
industry
is more concerned with treating symptoms
with medications instead of addressing
the underlying cause
i'd like to hear your thought about that
so you know
the the fact that they call themselves
troll man the anti-intellectual makes me
think maybe this is not someone who's
actually contacting me
in good faith but these are good
questions one of the real problems with
the medical industry
and there's there's two different
reasons for this is that
the overwhelming focus is on symptoms
and and immediate causes rather than
maybe underlying causes
and this applies to you know so many
different conditions caused by
obesity or a sedentary lifestyle or
whatever the case may be that's a
problem and one of the things
that can be done to resolve that issue
is to go
sorry there's one other part of the
problem which is for the most part
doctors are paid for doing things to the
patient
you get paid or someone gets paid
payments happen for ordering tests for
doing
procedures etc rather than
how healthy can we keep this person so
that they don't
need as much medical care as we might be
able to sign them up for
there are some insurance co-ops
and in certain states there are systems
being developed
where doctors are compensated for
keeping people healthy
rather than for the number of things
that they order be done
but the question is an interesting one
because what he seems to be saying is
that's how the system works if you do
medicare for all that issue just gets
worse
no no no no one of the ideas of medicare
for all whether it's a national medicare
for all or a state-run medicare for all
is that you could actually change
reimbursement policy
and payment systems so that you start
rewarding doctors
for keeping patients healthy rather than
reimbursing
them based on how many different tests
and procedures can you order
so they're two different issues and it
does not follow logically
that medicare for all would simply mean
an exacerbation
of the broken system that we now have um
and it's important when
assuming that that was a good faith
question and maybe i'm silly for for
assuming that
uh these these are two different things
and i would argue that the issue
of treating symptoms and profiting from
doing stuff
could be more easily fixed under a
medicare for all
uh system and it's been widely studied
and we
we've talked about it before on the
bonus show today
kentucky's senate has voted to make it a
crime
to taunt or insult law enforcement
officers will this be made law and what
are the implications
and are there actual free speech
implications so often when the right
says
that's a first amendment violation has
nothing to do with the government
what about this we are going to talk
about that on the bonus show number two
spain is going to launch a trial of a
four day
working week not the whole country but
in spain there is a trial
and we've been interested in this topic
for some time we're going to talk about
it
and uh capitol police for all of the
people asking
how long is the national guard going to
be in dc how long are these fences going
to be up capitol police is now
moving forward on a plan to remove the
outer fence
and to make other security changes and
hopefully assuming
it's safe to do so that security
presence in washington dc is going to
start being diminished
and we're going to talk about it's
become highly politicized there's a lot
of political implications uh
uh to what is going on there um and the
right has been
bomb throwing quite a bit about national
guard in dc
seemingly forgetting that the reason the
national guard is there is because of
what the right did
on january 6th so all of those stories
and more on today's bonus show get
instant access by
signing up at joinpacman.com you can
also get access by making a five dollar
a month or greater pledge on patreon
at patreon.com davidpakmanshow i will
see you then
or otherwise back on tomorrow's show